So I'll update everybody regarding the Echelon 3 data for specifically for diffuse large B-cell
lymphoma. I think this doesn't require an introduction per se. This is the landscape of
targeted therapies available now, and on the far right is the most recent one FDA approved and is
on the NCCA guidelines based on the Echelon 3 trial. This is for patients with relapsed refractory
diffuse large B-cell lymphoma after two prior lines of therapy. They should not have received
any lanolamide-based therapy or burntuximab or dotin. They technically were either progression
after transplant or CAR or were ineligible for either of these. Had to have good performance
status, measurable disease, and excluded CNS disease. The total number of patients on this
study was 230. They were randomized to the experimental arm, which is burntuximab or dotin,
at a dose of 1.2 milligrams per kilo every three weeks, plus rituxan and lanolamide. The lanolamide
dosing was 20 milligrams. The standard arm was placebo plus rituxan plus lanolamide at the same
doses. There was stratification based on CD30 status, cell of origin, prior CAR-T-cell therapy,
and prior transplant. And the primary endpoint here was overall survival in the intentivity
population, as well as the other endpoints noted on the slide there.
This data have already been presented. So just to summarize, first of all, in terms of the
treatment, the median number of prior therapies on this study was three, with 70% of patients having
stage three or four disease, 60% of patients had IPIs three or higher, and 20, sorry, 30% of
patients had prior CAR-T, and 20% of the patients had prior Bispecific. So reasonably
heavily pre-treated patient population. And here you can see the response rates on the left-hand
side.
64% overall response rates with 40% CRs in comparison to the lanolamide rituxan experimental
arm. And there isn't really a trend, just to suffice it to say, whether there were CD30
negative by less than 1% or positive, there is indeed a response there. And I'll come back to
this in just a little bit. In terms of the progression-free survival and overall survival
curve, you can see here, respectively on the left and on the right-hand side, there is an
improvement in progression-free survival and improvement in overall survival in favor of the
brentuximab-based strategy in this third line setting. And this data is what has led to the
inclusion of the regimen in the NCCN guidelines and its availability for our patients. It's a
reasonably well-tolerated regimen of therapy. There is certainly with the addition of an extra
agent, there is increased toxicity in terms of cytopenia. So there's more neutropenia,
thrombocytopenia, and anemia. There is certainly more,
brentuximab-related neurotoxicity at 20% all grade and 4% grade 3 or 4. This was a dose-reduced
regimen, so at least that mitigates some of the neurotoxicity, but really nothing beyond that
that stood out. In regards to what was updated this year at ASH was really this data regarding
CD30 expression. And just to summarize this quickly is that really CD30 expression is not,
visible CD30 expression by immunohistochemistry is not required for response. So you can see
on the left-hand side there, the overall response rate in the lenalidomide, sorry, in the BV lenalidomide
group, and then looking at with or without any significant expression, there's not a substantial
difference. And that just, this highlights really, first of all, for those of you who are familiar
with the studies that are done with brentuximab and dotin in CD30 positive disease, we did,
this in peripheral T-cell lymphoma, in lymphomotor papulosis, which is universally CD30 positive.
And in other studies, our method of detection for CD30 expression is immunohistochemistry,
and that's a visible technique. So that's clearly, as you can see, both here and in
many other studies, that visible IHC-based strategy is not adequate for assessment of
target.
Whereas here, even in the absence of a visible CD30 expression, there's actually clear responses
with clear benefit there. And this is also more broadly not limited to CD30. The same
thing happens when we do immunohistochemistry for assessment of CD19, CD20, CD22. Those
techniques are limited, perhaps at least in CD19 and 20. You have a little bit of a more
sensitive technique by flow cytometry, so you can enhance the technique.
But again, it's a little bit more specific, but it's a little bit more sensitive technique by flow cytometry, so you can enhance the technique. But again,
highlights the broader point that our IHC techniques are not adequate for detection of the target that
we are going after. And to summarize this data in terms of, again, this impact of CD30, visible CD30
expression here, really across the board, there seems to be a benefit in some of these categories,
like progression-free survival and overall survival. There's actually a statistically
significant hazard ratio there. So really establish that there's a significant impact on CD30 expression.
So really establish that there's a significant hazard ratio there. So really establish that there's a significant hazard ratio there.
really establishes the availability of this regimen. And this is indeed on the updated NCCN
guidelines as third line and beyond another strategy. The duration of remissions with this,
the duration of responses with this strategy is relatively short. So certainly as a palliative
strategy or perhaps the patients that are needed bridging to an allotransplant or other subsequent
lines of therapy, it's perhaps some utility there. So I'll stop there. Thank you.
Okay.